-Welcome to the show, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
Guys, it is Groundhog Day.
Yeah.
[ Cheers ]
That's right, this morning,
Punxsutawney Phil predicted
six more weeks of classified
documents being found.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, Punxsutawney Phil
predicted six more weeks
of winter.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
But I read --
I read that he's only right
40% of the time.
[ Laughter ]
When they heard that,
weather.com was like,
"You're hired.
When can you start?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you can't trust
Punxsutawney Phil.
He's basically the George Santos
of the groundhog world.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, in New York,
we've got a groundhog
named Staten Island Chuck.
[ Cheers ]
You know him? Yeah.
And he --
he predicted an early spring.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, technically he predicted
an "early friggin' spring."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Staten Island Chuck
hits it a little different.
He just comes out
with his robe open,
grabs the paper,
and goes back inside.
[ Laughter ]
"How's your sister doing?
All right, hey."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this morning up in Canada,
they held a celebration
with their own groundhog,
named Fred,
but things didn't go as planned.
This is real.
Take a look.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughter ]
-Not Fred.
-Every parent is like,
"What are you doing?
Just buy another groundhog
and say it's Fred!"
[ Laughter ]
"Look how great -- look how
great Fred looks today.
He looks fantastic."
[ Laughter ]
"Fred, he has blond hair now.
It's unbelievable."
-That's not --
-Why would you do that?
Now I'm just worried
that they'll never know
if it's gonna be cold in Canada.
[ Laughter ]
Who knows what happened to Fred?
Staten Island Chuck was like,
"I didn't see nothin'."
[ Laughter ]
"Don't worry 'bout it.
Hey, is your sister good?
All right."
[ Laughter ]
Switching -- Switching gears,
you guys see this last night?
White House chief of staff
Ron Klain
officially stepped down.
And during his farewell speech,
he got a little emotional.
Check it out.
-I will try to keep this brief,
but I cannot promise
there will not be some tears.
[ Voice breaking ] This is
the best job I've ever had.
And for dead again,
in the winter of 2020
and for dead again
in the winter of 2021.
I'm often asked,
"What is the best souvenir
I got in two years
as White House chief of staff?"
[ Voice breaking ]
It's this rock.
[ Laughter ]
This plain, and simple rock.
-Aww.
-Biden was like, "I think
we made the right call.
Someone get him into --"
[ Laughter ]
"Let's get him into --
get you an Uber right now."
-He's busted up over Fred.
[ Laughter ]
-He was only there two years.
Tom Brady was in football
for 23 seasons.
This guy...
I don't know.
This is going viral, though.
Today, Pope Francis
posted a tweet, and then, a few
minutes later, he deleted it,
and I think you'll
understand why. He said...
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, God was like,
"Jesus Christ..."
[ Laughter ]
"Get him off Twitter.
Get him into an Uber."
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
Netflix is about to start
cracking down
on password sharing.
[ Crowd booing ]
Yeah.
They're gonna limit sharing
to one household.
People --
[ Crowd booing ]
People are upset.
I mean, "Never Have I Ever"
been this outraged.
[ Laughter ]
I'm "Blown Away."
You're telling me I can't share
an account with a "Stranger?"
"Things" are out of control.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix, what
"Maid" "You" do this?
I can't think
of a "Dahmer" idea.
[ Laughter ]
This really takes "The Crown."
You're telling me I have to
"Lupin" every "Watcher"
on my account, including my
friend "Emily in Paris"?
[ Laughter ]
And say,
"I Think you Should Leave."
[ Laughter ]
What "A Series
of Unfortunate Events."
Sure I could pay extra,
but I'm already paying too much
for "Coco, melons," eggs.
Also, who knows
when this takes effect.
It could be tomorrow.
It could be --
could be next "Wednesday."
Or tonight at "Midnight.
Mass" panic is setting in.
[ Laughter ]
So, Netflix, this is the
"Last Chance U" have
before I build a "Bridgerton"-el
to your headquarters
and tell you in person,
"You're 'Dead To Me.'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
"This little rock --"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, get this --
Tomorrow, the movie
"80 for Brady" comes out,
which --
[ Cheers and applause ]
...which Tom Brady stars in,
and he suggested that
there could be more acting
in his future.
Yeah, Brady's a very good actor
'cause right now we all believe
that he's actually gonna retire.
[ Laughter ]
Some more entertainment news --
I saw that Tom Hanks is filming
a new movie that's using
artificial intelligence
to de-age him
and make him look younger.
It's -- It's amazing
what they can do now.
Just look at what happens when
you use A.I. to de-age someone.
For instance,
here's King Charles, okay?
If you de-age him,
you get Cap'n Crunch.
And it's like --
[ Laughter ]
It's amazing technology.
-Wow.
-Amazing.
-Fantastic.
-Here, Pope Francis --
here's Pope Francis.
You de-age him,
you get Timothée Chalamet.
And it's just --
[ Laughter ]
It's an amazing -- here --
here's Patrick Mahomes.
If you de-age him you get
Richie from "Family Matters."
[ Laughter ]
Next, here's the old guy
from "Up."
If you de-age him,
you get George Santos.
[ Laughter ]
It's -- It's happening.
I mean, the future is here.
Here's Eagles center
Jason Kelce.
-Yeah?
-If you de-age him,
you get Buzz from "Home Alone."
[ Laughter ]
Next, here's President Biden.
If you de-age him,
you get Bob Barker.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And finally --
finally, here's Tom Brady.
If you de-age him,
you get Tom Brady.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Doesn't need A.I.
Good-looking dude.
He doesn't need it.
Finally, police in Massachusetts
are looking for
a 200-pound Shrek sculpture
that was stolen.
This is real.
Can we see a photo of the --
[ Laughter ]
Looks like a cake someone made
on "Nailed It."
[ Laughter ]
Even the sculptor was like,
"I can't believe
someone stole that."
We have --
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen!
-♪ People know my city
gotta mesmerize ♪
♪ Block away in a house
from the 2-1-5 ♪
♪ To beat poetry
would be my every day ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-Come on.
-We have a big show tonight.
-Oh.
-Big show tonight.
Tomorrow, though,
for the first time ever --
very interesting --
for the first time ever,
The Roots will not be
the house band
for "The Tonight Show."
-Whoa.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Yeah.
-They didn't know that?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
[ Voice breaking ]
And they got a --
I gave them a little rock
to take --
[ Laughter ]
For the -- they actually --
Can we say what you're --
what you're doing?
-Yeah, you can say it.
-You're part of a giant
performance at The Grammys.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-50 --
50 years of hip hop.
-Yeah.
-And you guys are in charge
of all -- you'll be playing
with a bunch of --
-A lot of people.
-Yeah.
Should I say --
Can I say of these names?
-You can say some, yeah.
-I can?
-Yeah.
-I can say Busta Rhymes?
-You can say it.
[ Cheers ]
-I can say Missy Elliott?
-Can't say that.
[ Cheers ]
-Can I say Grandmaster Flash?
-Oh, yeah.
-Sure, sure.
-You can say it.
-Can I say Ice-T?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers ]
-Can I say Lil Wayne?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers ]
-Can I say Public Enemy?!
-What?!
-Can I say Queen Latifah?!
-Whoa!
-Can I say Run-D.M.C.?!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, that's gonna be massive.
-It is.
-I'm very excited about that.
It's cool.
And, also, are you still doing
your Grammy party?
-Yeah, yep.
-Is that the night --
-I forgot, yes, we are.
-The night before.
-You have that, as well.
Gosh, you're busy this weekend.
So, anyways, we're going,
"Well, who --
who should be the band
for our -- for our show?"
Our first time -- we've never
had to think of
who would be here if The Roots
weren't here.
And I was like, my first thing
that came to my mind is,
"I wonder if he would do it,
but could we get Paul Shaffer
to come back to the building?"
And I called Paul Shaffer,
and he said yes.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Paul Shaffer and
the World's Most Dangerous Band
are back at NBC after 30 years.
I cannot wait.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love Paul.
Everyone's coming.
Felicia, Anton.
It's gonna be fantastic.
I'm so excited about that.
Guys, we have a great show
for you tonight.
He stars in the giant new show
"The Last of Us,"
which airs Sundays
on HBO and HBO Max.
And he is hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend,
with musical guest Coldplay --
Pedro Pascal is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's good dude.
-A lovely man.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-Plus, you can see her
in the new movie
"Ant-Man and The Wasp:
Quantumania,"
which is in theaters and IMAX
February 17th --
Kathryn Newton is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got great music
from Armani White!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's real good.
Fantastic.
History of hip hop.
This dude --
This guy's gonna be on the list.
Apparently, guys, the FDA
is going to regulate CBD.
-Really?
-Yeah, I heard -- yeah.
And there's a new form of A.I.
called ChatGPT.
And then people are wondering
who's gonna be the NFL MVP.
There's a lot of acronyms...
-Floating in the air.
-...floating in the news,
including some
you might not know about.
This is "Acronym News."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Acronym News,
Acronym News ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-Now, I didn't know this,
but it turns out Brady
is an acronym for...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-Did you know that?
-I did not know that.
-Yeah, here's another one.
TikTok is actually
an acronym for...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just found out this, that
"Santos" is an acronym for...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-These are all --
-That's --
These are all acronyms?
-After last --
Yes, these are all --
After last weekend's big win...
-Yeah?
-...Eagles is an acronym for...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You can't stop me."
Can't stop people.
-He said it.
-Here's an interesting one here.
-What's that?
-Trump is an acronym for...
[ [ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Wow!
-Finally, Southwest
is an acronym for...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all for "Acronym News."